what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the idea of federalism which
is core to the united states government
now federalism the word originates its
root comes from the latin word fetus
which i'm probably not pronouncing
perfectly but it's in reference to
things like a treaty an agreement a
contract a league or a pact and
federalism you can view as a pact
between a national government and its
states it's referring to a government
that has various layers where you could
have the
national government
often known as the federal government
and then you have the states
and you're going to have multiple states
over here and then you could have even
further layers and in the united states
you indeed do you have the local
governments
and even within the local you have city
governments you have county governments
the analogy that's often made is
originally the federal idea was kind of
like a layered cake so this is my best
attempt at drawing a quick
layered cake
where you could view each layer as one
of the layers of government so when i
cut open that cake maybe right over here
this blue layer right over here it's
blue flavored cake maybe it's an ice
cream cake of some kind that might be
the federal government then this yellow
maybe it's mango flavored that would be
the state government
and then you have your
strawberry flavored
local government that is one view of
federalism but it turns out in the
united states especially over the
passage of time this has gotten mixed up
a little bit so even though the united
states might have started a little bit
closer to something like this layered
cake today it is more of a marble cake
where the different layers and their
powers are more mixed together and so
that's my attempt to drawing these
the mixing of these various powers and
not only do they mix they overlap that
different layers of our federal
government some have exclusive powers
which means they are the only layer that
has them well some of them while
sometimes there are concurrent powers
which means these are powers that
multiple layers might actually have now
to appreciate what these exclusive and
concurrent powers are
here's a venn diagram that shows some of
them so on the left hand side right over
here you have your exclusive federal
powers so in the united states only the
federal government can coin money you
can't have money from texas or
california
only the federal government can declare
war which is related to the idea of
conducting foreign affairs which only
which once again only the federal
government can do that's also related to
raising armies once again only the
federal government rules of
naturalization who becomes an immigrant
who gets a green card who becomes a
citizen all determined by the federal
government not by the states and the
federal government regulates not just
foreign affairs but foreign commerce
trade agreements and how is trade done
they're regulating between the states
now exclusive powers to the states they
conduct elections you might say wait
hold on a second well aren't there
federal elections well it turns out even
for say election for president the
elections are conducted by the state
government remember we have the
electoral college they want to figure
out who who is who should that state's
electors vote for
establishing local governments what are
the counties what are the
what are the various jurisdictions
within a state similarly intrastate
commerce that's regulated by the state
what about the commerce that happens
within the state
and then the constitution allows the
states to be the main power in ratifying
constitutional amendments the senate and
house can propose amendments but three
fourths of the states have to vote to
ratify constitutional amendments
now what we see in the middle of this
venn diagram these are concurrent powers
which means that they are common to both
federal and state governments you can
have federal taxes and you can have
state taxes in fact most of us have both
there are federal laws and there are
state laws
similarly there's federal law
enforcement you can think of the fbi
federal bureau of investigation and of
course you have state police and local
police
the chartering of banks
eminent domain which we might do another
video on in the future but this is the
idea that
a government can view
taking
land as the interest of the broader good
in order to put down power lines or
highway and ideally compensate the
people that it takes from if it's for
the greater good
establishing courts you have a federal
court system and a state court system
which we'll talk more about in future
videos and borrowing money they both can
issue bonds if they want to have a large
project or to finance their deficit all
of these things are concurrent powers
now this list is not exhaustive for any
one of the three for the exclusive
federal powers the concurrent power so
i'll do this dot dot dot here and the
exclusive state powers
and one thing that you will see even
certain exclusive state powers so for
example education
is for the most part considered an
exclusive state power but then you might
say hold on a second isn't there a
federal department of education i'll do
that over here
and the way and this is a good example
of how the federal government even when
something might be more of a exclusive
state power where the federal government
can still influence it and they do that
through grants so even though the states
and local governments might run the
schools the federal government might say
hey if you do x y and z which we want
you to do then we will give you more
funding for your schools and so that
might be motivation for the states to
listen to the federal government
so i will leave you there this is super
important to understand if you want to
understand how the united states works
and frankly most governments in the
world today